when I post more shorts I can feel that
subscriber growth more than when I'm
just doing my regular uploads for sure
the biggest mistake new content creators
make is not releasing anything until
they think it's perfect what do you
think independent creators since now
you've lived in both worlds could learn
from what you learned in traditional
media the most important mindset you
need as a content creator is that you
are talking to one person that's
everything I think welcome back to the
think media podcast in this episode I'm
going to be talking to a creator that
has generated 1.9 million views in the
last 6 months she's going to be breaking
down her strategy she's actually growing
10,000 subscribers per month but there
was a season recently where views were
down subscribers were down and she was
kind of in a YouTube recession and maybe
you can relate to that and so we're
going to be unpacking the story of orle
the DIY designer today she has over
460,000 subscribers she's also the
creator of hash style language which is
a viral personal style concept with 5.5
million hits on Tik Tok we're going to
be talking about long form short form
she's going to be unpacking her secrets
and talking about how she monetizes and
has really built a business around all
of this orle welcome to the think media
podcast what's up thank you so much for
having me how fun for those that are
just meeting you can you break down what
it is you do on YouTube and just kind of
your background and fashion DIY fashion
and how you ended up here 100% so you
know it's so funny t uh YouTube has
always felt to me like an accident in a
weird way because I've grown up my whole
life making clothes it's always
something I've done I come from a family
of artists A family of entrepreneurs you
know if you have an idea for something
chances are what you want doesn't exist
and you make it that's just like the
mentality of my whole family growing up
a huge portion of my life had to do with
style and fashion and how much I loved
that and how much I loved the ability to
customize and really communicate who you
are through your style and then there
was a a a separate love that was
entertaining and you know being on
camera and being myself on camera and
those worlds kind of merged and I'd say
you know the last probably 10 or 15
years of my career has really been more
traditionally on on television shows
doing this stuff on TV and I'd say it
was maybe like my third or fourth year
on a show called home family which is a
daytime talk show on Hallmark where I
started feeling really disconnected from
my own aesthetic and my own voice and my
own personality and way of showing up on
camera like I was I was a hallmarked
version of myself which is not super me
um not super me and so I literally went
to YouTube just to have a place where I
could continue to do creative things
talk about the things I loved but in my
own voice where I was the only one in
charge the DIY could be something I
thought were cool The Voice could be my
own the tone could be my own and so
that's all it was supposed to be and I
think it's now been I mean I don't know
maybe it's six years six or seven years
that I've been doing it and yeah you
know I think this month hit like 530,000
subscribers which is you know it it
continues to confuse me like wait what's
happening you know how did and when you
jumped out did you go from
traditional support of Hallmark filming
and things like that to completely Indie
how did you launch your YouTube channel
well a huge reason I was able to launch
was my brother so my brother his name is
Ben Shanny um Ben Shanny creative if you
follow him on Instagram he is a
videographer and a photographer and my
like cre my like creative soulmate like
we really really are very very close and
he has supported me in every cookie
Endeavor I've ever wanted to do and and
he supported me in a way that he's made
it look profession professional he's
made it looked polished he's made it
looked bigger than it was from the get
and that's the same with rockot I I have
a brand and he does all the photography
for that for the website and so he's
always allowed me to feel a little bit
more legit than I felt at the time and
so he shot everything for me and in the
beginning he shot all of the DIYs like I
would physically di I would only worry
about making what I was making and he
would film and he would do close-ups and
he would edit and I would sit next to
him while he edited and I would explain
like no no no we we don't actually need
that okay no no no that part but then
can you make that slow you know and I
would walk him through it and I don't
know when it was maybe it was a year and
a half in or two years in it just wasn't
sustainable he was you know out of town
filming and doing bigger jobs and so I
started filming it myself I started
editing it myself and it all became
something that I did 100% on my own
except for if anyone follows my YouTube
channel they know it well the sort of
like modeling session at the end of
every video where I wear and style the
thing I made made and I you know very
embarrassingly walk up and down my block
and wave at my neighbors and I'm like
yes I'm that person you know modeling on
the street right now um he films that
part but the rest I do myself and you
know and I think that that is one of the
hardest parts I think about being a
content creator that gets a little sort
of on by I I'll give you an example I
have a a good friend who I actually was
in business with for a while and he is
super funny super smart super successful
and has a big mouth and it's everything
that I love about him and one of the I
remember him going on a rant he has a
podcast I remember from going on a rant
he was talking about this burnout
YouTube burnout Creator burnout and just
the entire tone of the conversation was
this incredibly overwhelming eye roll
like seriously it's because you guys
have never worked a day in your life and
now like you know throwing out these fun
videos where you dance around is so hard
like oh my God and I so bad we wanted to
call him and be like I have the benefit
of perspective because I came from
traditional television and I know that
not only is every Department its own
Department with multiple people but
there are multiple departments to make
this one thing happen and so when I was
doing a DIY segment I had a producer who
only who their only job was to come up
with ideas then I had a producer whose
only job was to figure out the order of
how the actual segment would go and I
had someone who did hair and makeup and
I had someone who did wardrobe and we
had cameramen and we had editors and we
had a marketing department and we had
social media and we had every arm
multiple people in every department and
when you are building a YouTube channel
you are not only every individual you
are every department and it is a lot of
jobs and it is a lot of work and so it
is so infuriating to me when people make
it as though it's not a real job because
what what we're doing success f is we're
making it look easy we're sending you a
little fun seven minute segment that's
perfectly packaged and the personality
and the fun and the light and the music
and the sound effects are all there to
make it feel like a pop of ease but what
it takes to create that pop of ease is a
tremendous amount of work and so it's
all I almost want to be like you're
falling for it you're falling for how
easy it looks like that's what we is
successful right but it is really an
incredible amount of work and so the an
incredibly long answer to your question
is yeah I do it as a one-woman show and
I do it
entirely on my own um except for the
modeling session which my brother still
shoots and when you first picked up the
camera and picked up a video editor what
was that learning curve like was it
rough at first did you have some
previous experience how did you by maybe
being in design maybe you had the eye
for shot composition but even just
camera operation settings and things
like that how did you accelerate your
learning curve once you took every
aspect of basically video creation upon
yourself individually well I will say
that right after I graduated high school
I moved to New York City and I went to a
school called the New York Film Academy
and at the time I really loved I I I've
always loved the idea of creating worlds
and creating stories and I thought that
directing would be a really cool way of
taking all of those interests and so I
went to school and while I don't think
that I apply much of what I learned as
far as shot composition or storytelling
there I do think that the editing piece
there was some kind of muscle memory
that I was able to actually retain it
while I watched Ben edit I actually
remembered a little bit of how to do it
and as soon as I got back into trying it
myself there was a short hand that I was
like oh wait I remember this like
command B like I just remembered funky
little things even though I hadn't done
it in in such a long time so I do think
part of it is that the other piece I
think is really really just my
experience in front of the camera in
that limited role I got to see what
everyone else did and I got to learn
from people who are the best at what
they do and see the things that they're
concerned about and and even you know
for example like on home and family that
was like live DIY boot camp you know it
was a five day a week two hour a day 52
week a year daytime talk show um taped
you know live to tape and so seeing the
camera guys and rehearsing all talk
about like okay once you you're going to
you're going to focus on this one moment
wait till you see the camera cut hold
hold until you see we've got at least
three seconds and then move on and we'll
cut watch it watch it and let it breathe
for a second like they taught me they
trained me in what they needed so that
when I was then doing it on my own I
knew what I was going to need when I was
editing I knew I was going to need a
still moment to cut into and I was going
to need enough of a breather for the
audience to grab it and then move on and
so if I'm moving too fast I can't use
any of that yet we've got to settle like
I just learned from them I think and
then it's just mimicked like you do it
and you're like that feels good that
feels familiar you know and and it's
amazing how quick you can learn and as
far as camera settings are concerned I
use Auto settings always like I leave
the fancy stuff to my brother I use Auto
settings on mine with the auto light
adjuster and like all of that stuff
because again it's it's one too many
jobs you know if I'm focusing on trying
to actually create a pattern and sew and
I'm too obsessed with worrying about
changing the settings it's it's too many
distractions in my brain so I rely on
those Auto settings and I think you know
take some of the weight off of needing
the best of the best you know and and
really rely on some of the amazing
technology that these cameras have now
in the background of your shot we could
see a tripod and a camera and a shotgun
microphone what camera are you using for
creating your videos so I use a Canon it
is the Canon M50 I believe um I'd have
to even look at it I mean I bought it
probably three years ago now um and it's
just a it's it's to me I knew the thing
that I wanted the most was obviously a
camera that had great you know picture
quality but that had obviously the you
know uh screen that I could Bend back to
myself so I could make sure that I was
recording and that things were still you
know in frame I I really looked for
something that was going to be super
userfriendly had good automatic settings
and then again just had a screen that I
could flip towards myself for the most
basic needs and it's worked beautifully
for what I need and then what kind of
video editing software are you editing
on I use Final Cut and it's you know I
have found it to be so easy and it's
what I used when I was in film school so
it it feels really familiar to me and I
think like I even I have a girlfriend
who uses uh iMovie and I was like you
know as soon as you're ready the jump to
Final Cut will be so easy because it's
all the same kind of you know it's it's
just the grown-up version of that in a
sense and so if you're starting on
iMovie you know knowing that Final Cut
Is building on those building blocks
whereas maybe Premiere or whatever is a
little bit of a of a shifting in your
perspective learning things and thinking
of it in a different way um and and I
love it I mean it's it's given me
everything that I need yeah here at
think media we agree I think uh there's
a lot of good video editing softwares
but the iMovie Final Cut Mac or MacBook
workflow is definitely like the easiest
I think most streamlined workflow if you
can uh get all of those tools and even
Nolan Mt created a fulllength free
basically Final Cut course that just
exists on YouTube it's like two hours
it's like he teaches you everything and
so um if anyone's interested we'll link
that up in the show notes but I I
actually want to hang on uh your time at
Hallmark in traditional television with
a question of what do you think
independent creators since now you've
lived in both worlds could learn from
what you learned in traditional media
and what is also a mistake you think
that traditional make media is making
now in light of your experience boots on
the ground of New Media Creation in
social media you know I've had an
interesting career in in the more
traditional media I was on a competition
show on NBC and then I hosted two shows
on the E network that were style shows
and I did fashion police and live from
the red carpet and you know doing the
Today Show and access and kind of having
uh an interesting experience bouncing
through all of these worlds and I think
that the one thing that I have realized
is everybody's really scared everybody's
really scared and no one necessarily has
a real Vision because no one's really in
charge and even who is in charge isn't
really in charge and even that person
who's in charge isn't really in charge
and so people are very scared to take a
risk people are very scared to follow a
gut and it can
become it it can become a little bit of
like a I I don't know how to describe it
it almost feels like you're like a buoy
in the water and and everyone's just
kind of bouncing around these waves and
the waves take different directions on
different days and everyone's just sort
of on this weird ride there's no one
there's no anchor um and and that's the
one thing that I think has been very
very cool and very a breath of fresh air
about the content creation space is like
you are your own anchor and you get to
make very clear decisions based off very
clear gut feelings and you get to have a
very clear voice and you don't have to
be so confused all the time and try to
check everyone else's boxes when those
boxes change every few years and you
contort yourself and mold yourself into
something to check the boxes today and
then when they change you're like
yesterday's news and you're like no no
no but like I can be that too like it's
a it's a it's a trap you know it's
really exhausting and so I do think that
traditional media is looking
and in love with creators who who are
authentically who they are and create
this entire universe around them where
everyone Buys in but then we've all seen
that moment where they make the move to
traditional and all of a sudden all of
the voices get in there and sort of un
authenticate them in everything that
made them special it's just different
it's a sort of it's a it's a bit of a
corporate machine and there are biggest
bigger interests at play and it it gets
very confusing and so I wish that that
traditional media would trust the like
very realtime feedback that the audience
provides I think the audience engagement
on social media should be telling you
more than the ratings like a neelen
rating and the fact that a show could
trend on Twitter and then get cancelled
for bad ratings like something's off we
we're not we're not looking at the same
information and so it's the same as like
film I feel like that happens in film
you know the the Barbie movie was such a
great example like it blew up and took
over the world in such an impactful way
but you know movies continuously get
made with different goals or different
directions or different audiences in
mind when the audience will tell you
what it wants the you know social media
and and and I think that that is one of
the reasons that the content creation
digital space has a leg up but it's
still like not fully taken
as seriously or with as much weight
which I think is a real mistake realtime
audience feedback is priceless and for
the small Creator um that's not the
season they're in at least on their
personal content before you're getting
comments before you're getting that
feedback but for the established Creator
we it's such a powerful perspective you
just shared of us not re really
considering how valuable it is that not
only can we create content but we have a
continuous feedback loop which can help
us make better content that resonates
Ates more and steer away if we start to
miss it um because it's not doesn't have
all the corporate red tape or drama
around it we just are direct to Consumer
I want to talk about a while ago you I
don't remember where we talked it might
have been on a coffee with canel and you
were going through a season where views
were down growth was down now if we look
at your channel 1.1 million views in the
last
28 days 10,000 new subscribers almost 8
million views over the last six months
52,000 new subscribers so clearly in a
way you kind of revived a dead Channel
your channel wasn't dead but that's
that's a language a lot of people think
about like oh my channel died like the
algorithm killed my channel how do I
revive it how do I get my channel alive
again you've been doing that what what
has changed did you just get consistent
did you just persevere through the
valley of death or is there anything
else you've tried yeah man Sean it is
such
a disheartening feeling it really is and
like anybody and and this is a feeling
that like you know you almost don't want
to feel because it there's a little bit
of Shame around it and there's a little
bit of embarrassment around it but for
the new Creator who's just coming to
YouTube who's just thinking about
creating a channel who feels like
they're working their butt off and
they're not getting traction and they're
not getting views or the Creator who was
very much like me who felt like they had
tremendous success and then you're like
what happened there it is very hard not
to take it personally it is it it feels
embarrassing it feels like you're a
loser like literally these core little
Middle School feelings like you didn't
get picked first that stuff comes up for
you as a you're we're creative people
most of us are in touch with our
emotions and connected to that piece and
so we feel this stuff we really do and
it it it was very hard it continues to
be very hard I remember so vividly there
was a a girl who is actually one of the
reasons I started my YouTube channel she
had come on Hallmark as a guest but she
was a YouTuber and I was at the place in
my time there where I was like I think I
need an outlet and I I went to her
studio in Downtown LA and her and her
husband had run her Channel together and
she was telling me all about how she
started and gave me really you know
great advice of you know pick a set day
and pick a time and let people get used
to it and just be consistent and I
always kept track of her like she was
always someone I kept track of and I
remember so vividly that after my first
year maybe when things were going really
well I hadn't had 100,000 subscribers
yet but every video was doing over like
100,000 views on every video it was
crazy and I remember looking at her
Channel and seeing that she had 700,000
subscribers and videos were getting like
7,000 views and I
remember having a deep fear like a
literal deep fear I'm like oh my God
like does that happen like does it not
just keep going up and up and up like
does that happen and why does that
happen and when that happens what do you
do and I and and then I remember feeling
like oh my God it happened it happened
it just fell off a cliff and there were
different reasons you know one of the
things that that we talked about when we
were talking about doing this was about
how I had hired an agency to help
because I was like I don't know what the
hell's going on but it literally feels
like my channel is just being like
ghosted and it's existing in a bubble
and nobody even knows it's there anymore
and so I hired this company to help me
and the and the company didn't really do
anything but one of the things that they
did bring to my attention was that
during
covid um I did a video in in March like
that March of 2020 um of how to make
your own face masks when face masks were
you couldn't find them they were
non-existent and I was making them out
of old pillowcases and t-shirts how to
make it for the size of your face and
all of this stuff and the video blew up
and and you know blew up ble up but the
problem was that it blew up in such a
with such a wide varied audience right
it like people from all over the world
cared about this video people of every
gender people of every race people of
every age people of every interest level
needed this and all of a sudden my
channel was like wait what like who are
we who likes us and what they believed
was that then it was still sending my
videos out to just as many people but
only a tiny fraction after cared about
that content because it was no longer a
life-saving necessity it was like how to
shred your jeans you know and this guy
who lived in Spain was trying to make a
maser's family couldn't give a crap
about that and so that's what they
thought happened and so it could have
just literally been it took that long to
redefine my audience and get very clear
again about what I was I do think like
you said consistency was a big thing
there was quite a few chunks of time
where I was so disheartened I just took
months off and I was just like screw
this like what am I doing you know and I
just sort of
stopped and so I've definitely been more
consistent that's all I can really say
because it's so funny until you sent me
the screenshots of like your channel is
doing well I I didn't even really know
that like I just am like I'm gonna stay
consistent you know and and actually the
whole reason I decided to stay
consistent is so I when I had that show
on E I hosted it with Kristen cavalary
who is like the best human ever side
note like just the most wonderful such a
girl's girl so much fun just I love her
to death and we were texting and and you
know her brand uncommon James has become
really successful and she has a full
staff to do all of the things and I have
launched this business called rockot and
it's doing really well but I am still a
one-woman show and I was like God I'm so
jealous of you right now that like
you've got this whole team and I was
like you know YouTube has been really
hard but I think of YouTube as my life
Money YouTube is my mortgage YouTube is
my groceries I want to keep the rockot
money in rockot so I can hire someone
and I can this and she's like well then
shut up and hustle get YouTube going
again what are you doing she's like
hustle that until you don't need it but
come on and it was like that click that
I needed like YouTube is my day job
Hustle work the day job do it do it do
it and that's when I got consistent
again and that's when I think it started
growing again hey and just a second
we're going to get back into the episode
but if you haven't heard for a limited
time you can get OnDemand access to my
YouTube strategy class entirely for free
at think masterclass.com on the class
you're going to learn the one strategy
that we use at think media that is
currently generating over 300,000 views
every single day if you are new to
YouTube this is going to help you start
right and avoid mistakes and if you're
already a pro this is going to help you
multiply your growth and the cool thing
is the class is 100% free and you can
watch it instantly on demand all you got
to do is go to
think.com or just click the link in the
show notes to get instant access all
right let's jump back into the episode
there's a lot in there um I mean one
redefining your audience I think that
it's a challenge that many creators can
relate to I know at think
media um we've done many things well the
vision has been clear the best tips and
tools for building your influence with
video but one of the challenges with
doing a deep Final Cut training is it
attracts people that want Final Cut they
want video editing but they may not want
a camera and they may not want YouTube
advice and now we've done that for so
many years that we have attracted an
audience that although specific is is
diverse and we always Say Never upload a
video your subscribers didn't subscribe
for and there's no doubt about it that
like conditioning the algorithm your
language of redefining the algorithm and
if someone said well how do I do that
well sounds like one way to do that is
to get clear on your vision again get
back to consistency again and also
persevere through that season of all
kinds of external Dynamics but of maybe
the falloff of different audience
members that just watched because of a
mask video during the pandemic and now
it's kind of YouTube discovering your
core audience again but you ended so
powerfully too with just the mindset I
think our mindset is honestly fragile I
think it's just fragile as humans I
think we have a fragile mindset in
general but any creators as well like I
don't know why we act tough or think
we're uh you know think that we have it
all together you mentioned scared
earlier I think we could relate to that
you know scared will this last um am I
doing it wrong am I going to mess the
whole thing up did I just ruin my whole
future and career because I messed the
algorithm up there's just a lot of
mindset things that can um cause us to
be paralyzed and not post but ultimately
as you got back as you got consistent um
you are proof that you got out of that
even just seeing your views on
individual videos and your views across
the channel That a channel that has hit
a recession or that has died can live
again and can be revived um you did
seven uploads this last month some
fulllength videos and some shorts what's
your current schedule and have you found
that to be sustainable so I release
every Sunday uh Sunday morning 5:15 a.m.
Pacific Standard time um is when I
release the videos and that you know I
don't miss um I mean that's the goal
right that that's my like upload upload
uh shorts I I am I can feel it in my gut
I am missing a huge Opportunity by not
prioritizing it and I know it like I can
feel it I know it whether YouTube
whether it's because YouTube is pushing
shorts or it's bringing a new audience
or it's just whatever it is it's just
another opportunity to clarify with the
algorithm like whatever it is um when I
post more shorts I can feel that
subscriber growth more than when I'm
just doing my regular uploads for sure
so I think that that's a really really
big piece of it and I know it's
something that I need to um prioritize
more it's just been a difficult one with
with time because oftentimes you know I
just hired TR and then I stopped hired
someone to help create shorts based off
my YouTube videos but because I edit
like I don't love the final edits I get
and so I'm not like super stoked to
upload them and so then time then I'm
like I've got them sitting in a folder
and I've you know I'm not I'm not doing
it as much whereas I know when I up when
I edit my own short it's something I
feel confident about it's got my voice
it's got my tone it's got the important
bits and it and I normally find that it
performs better but I think that if you
can get shorts of up it is a really
powerful tool for the rest of your
channel because it just feels like this
it's like this little free commercial
for your channel you know it's like this
30 second one minute bite-sized teaser
for people who maybe don't know what you
are and what you're about that might
pull them and be like oh [__] I didn't
know she does all this stuff there's a
new Full DIY video every week like and I
get that all the time like just
discovering this like people commenting
on three-year-old videos being like I'm
just starting down your rabbit hole this
is amazing like so I think really
thinking of shorts as being um a
conversation it's almost like thinking
of YouTube shorts like Tik Tok you don't
need any followers on Tik Tok for your
content to reach people who give a crap
about it that's the beauty that's why
Tik Tok has become such an exciting
place for so many people is that if it
is interest based not follower based not
subscriber based it's if you care about
this we're going to give you this
content from someone you've never heard
of and maybe you're going to start
following them and you're going to get
more of that content so YouTube shorts
is like that I think it's that
introduction it's sort of casting that
line out into the ocean and being like
anybody anybody um and so I can feel in
myself a wasted opportunity every week
that goes by that I you know I didn't
get one out um and I and I really really
recommend it I think it's incredibly
powerful are you doing a
multi-platform approach mentioned Tik
Tok and you created hashtag style
language are you active creating content
on any other platform and how do you
sustain that yeah so I um Tik Tok is the
other platform that I try to create as
often as I can on for that very reason
that the growth there is crazy like only
on for a year and a half maybe on Tik
Tok and at 200 and something thousand
subscribers there or followers there or
whatever which like compared to
Instagram which I've been on since
whatever 2012 and I have like a 100,000
and it's just like you're like crawling
this like slow sad crawl you know um Tik
Tok is exciting in that way and so the
the main content that has popped for me
has been style language content which
for those you know most of you I assume
that have no idea what the heck that is
um you know one of the main reasons that
I have always gravitated towards DIY is
the idea that our style is really only
supposed to communicate who we uniquely
are the idea of this aesthetic that's in
this trend that's in and sort of a
mimicking style and it's you know is
exhausting to me it's not what it's
supposed to be we're all supposed to
look different carry ourselves different
different energy different Vibes and
style is a really powerful tool and so
just like a love language you might have
a unique way that you give and receive
love that you actually express it and
feel it you have a style language it's a
unique way that you communicate who you
are through your physical appearance
it's a unique way that you feel most
confident most like yourself when you're
dressed with these unique blend of
elements that all come together in your
way you're like yeah that's me that's
when I feel me and it's a combination of
three or four words so for example mine
is sexy edgy effortless original and I
need all of those energies that's when I
feel like me if I was dressed super sexy
and like glamorous I would feel so
embarrassed I would feel so cheesy I
would feel so out of my body but when I
create an effortless relaxed energy to
it and I add something that gives me a
little Edge and I do something that's
unique now I'm me now my personality can
shine now I'm showing up as my best self
and so DIY the fashion piece of it
always started because I didn't want to
buy something that someone else made for
me I wanted to make it my own I wanted
to speak my unique styling which I
wanted to customize it to be me and I
wanted to teach other people to do that
for themselves and so it was always kind
of my reasoning underneath everything I
did anyway um and as soon as I started
working on it as a concept and and
trying to write it as a book and all of
that stuff it developed into this like
method that had steps and tools and a
and an online course and it became its
own thing and so what what has been
really fun about Tik Tok is that there's
been an opportunity to create content
around it some of it is you know
tutorial demoing type of content where I
literally say like I'm going to wear
this camo jacket and I'm going to style
it for four totally different style
languages we're going to do this
language this language this and this and
you can see that it's not about the
clothes that you own but about the way
that you wear them you don't need to
spend a million dollar just tweak the
way you're presenting yourself and so
there's that piece then there is more a
thought a kernel of it that I want to
explain and I want to teach and I'm
eager to teach the information and then
there are people asking questions that
it's almost like a one-on-one where I
take their question and I answer it and
so that conversation is happening that
has really thrived and been very
exciting and something I've really
enjoyed and I try to bring it to
YouTube with so so success you know it's
a it doesn't hit quite as much when I do
it on YouTube but that's okay you know
different platforms how long does it
take you to
sustain the Tik Tok uh original Tik toks
per week that's a great question I don't
know the answer to that actually I think
that when I do the replies that's easy
because that's like that's like if I ask
you a question like you have all the
information in your brain all you got to
do is tell me about it like you don't
need to script it you don't need to
rehearse it you would have all the
answers of whatever question right so in
that sense that's very easy I literally
see a question I go outside and I and I
answer it um the when I shoot something
that is more of like a demonstration
styling and all of those things I'd say
that normally takes me all in about two
hours um to shoot and to edit and then
to get up and do the text and do all the
things that are like natively happening
within the Tik Tok platform um probably
about two hours so it it fluctuates but
it's you know this is a this is a season
in in my life right now that is that is
just you just very overwhelming it it
just is you know I I think there's a lot
of like for you do you what is your um
crew like to create the amount of
content that you create what's like your
team I think media counting contractors
is 30 people now yeah see that's just I
you I'm so
jealous I'm so jealous um see like that
is one thing that I have never quite
figured out is how to grow Beyond Myself
And so I've always felt a little limited
because it's really what I have the
capability of doing and with rockot
being as successful as it is that piece
is a huge piece of my day-to-day now I
hired someone to fulfill orders but we
had some hiccups and so we're taking a
minute to to figure out how we're going
to rectify that wrong are wrong items
going out and things like that um and so
I'm fulfilling orders and designing new
products and doing photo shoots and
making ads and making a YouTube video
every week and editing a short every
week and doing a Tik Tok video and doing
a styling like it's like it it is a lot
and I know it's not sustainable but
they're
all things that I think have tremendous
Futures and so I don't want to let any
of them die and that's what's what is
the struggle I want to cover
monetization income streams in just a
second um and
I do want to talk about a couple case
studies and what you learned from some
of your highest performing videos and
then we'll end with a kind of lightning
round segment and I first want to uh
touch on one of your better performing
videos in the last year was denim Trends
2022 seven easy ways to fray jeans
362,000 views and then you also a month
ago did I tried viral AI Tick Tock
dresses and that also did 290,000
views what have you learned
from those videos especially also
tapping into Trends related to your
Niche related to your topic and maybe
why those videos perform so well and how
you came up with them yeah so the trends
the trends video is an interesting one
because it's certainly didn't pop at
first and so I do think there's one of
those things where when we're ask when
we're thinking about our audience and
we're thinking about the kind of content
that we're providing to them there's
sort of two options one
is valuable searchable problemsolving
information that in in three or four
years from now they're G to it's going
to show up so learning how to do these
things with denim is going to be a video
that's going to continue to serve them
even though it wasn't exciting and viral
and like whoa everyone needs to see it
today it has grown because it is a
valuable always valuable piece of
content that Aggregates quite a few
different Trends together allinone very
in-depth how to do it um and so it's
grown it was not a video that seemed
like it was going to do really much of
anything but it kind of did over time
and then the dress the viral dress that
was a graphic that I had got sent
probably by 25 people where they would
just DM it to me on Instagram and it was
this image that looked like a big
rectangle with a couple of slits in it
and then the image would pull the dress
up and it created a dress and flatten
the dress out and pull the dress up and
flatten the dress out and it looked
literally like a rectangle with three
slits in it I tried it and it sucked it
didn't work and I'm like you know what
forget it this doesn't work it's just
stupid AI like man it's not real and
then I kept looking at it and I was like
there's a way to make this work work
like there's a way to make this actually
work and maybe it's not maybe it has to
be different from what the AI generated
one was and so I played around with it
and I figured it out and it turned out
to be this really great DIY now one of
the things that I think was good about
the video was that it was different
formatted differently than my others
because I was in New York I was on
vacation I had filmed the DIY portion of
it when I was in LA but I hadn't my
intro and I hadn't modeled it and I
hadn't done any of that stuff and so
when I was in New York walking through
the city going to meet my friends for a
drink I recorded my intro and it was on
the go and it was different than me in
my room like hey welcome to my you know
and I think that it probably grabbed
people initially it just felt fresh and
different um and I think that that was
part of it actually is even when there
was a there was a tweak of it I was in
my sister-in-law's backyard and like put
up my cell phone and I'm like Hey Okay
so there's this one thing that I had to
explain and like I'm in the middle of
some random place and I think those
things made the video feel new and fresh
to some people combined with the fact
that it was literally a 30- second dress
that required no sewing and it was
strategically placed cuts that you could
make into this really great piece and so
you know they they when they pop they
pop for different reasons but I I do
feel like part of it was that was just
the freshness of the intro and the ity
of the Tik Tok Instagram whatever dress
to begin with um and and that's one
thing that you know I have struggled
with I have really tried very hard to
stay away from those viral Trends
because I am not that girl like I'm not
that girl I'm not I'm not GNA do it
great I'm not going to nail it so I feel
like I have preferred to steer clear of
a little bit of that and just really
make something that I actually want to
own in my closet like that's really my
my my goal is I'm going to make this
thing and I'm going to teach you how you
can change it and customize it for you
so that it speaks your style language
and it reflects your style but I'm not
going to follow this trend that
everybody's doing I hate it I don't like
it so why would I do that so I've
started to trust my gut as far as my own
taste is concerned and not do something
that feels like it might be clickbaity I
learned that lesson with this cardi b
dress that I made it was this like
handkerchief dress and she was
everywhere like the photos went viral of
her wearing this handkerchief dress and
I looked at it I'm like I I mean I can
make that that's easy I can make that I
hated it but I made it and when the
video tanked it was even more
embarrassing because I felt like I was
trying to be someone I wasn't you know I
was like look at me make the viral Nicki
Minaj dress like I felt so like like
embarrassed of myself because it wasn't
like a video I loved that just didn't
pop it was like a video that I felt like
kind of a little bit of a wannabe doing
and then it didn't pop so then I was
even more embarrassed you know so I
think I've I've followed my gut a little
bit more more too powerful insights and
I think uh it seems like when you jumped
on the Tik Tok challenge Trend there was
it resonated with you so rather than
chasing a trend um if you feel it when
you feel it um jumping on that can be
powerful and it proved it was in the
views I also want to share one of my
favorite strategies that is a small
tweak that we do in video ranking
Academy our signature course um on the
seventh R it's repeat where you kind of
not just think about how can you make
your next video more intelligently based
off datadriven decisions but also one of
the habits of repeat is to look at your
channel and think about how you can
optimize old videos to give them new
life or to give them a longer lifespan
and this little power nugget for the
think media podcast I'm grateful you're
here wherever you watch or listen rate a
review smash like if it's on YouTube um
but your denim Trends 2022 video video
um amazing thumbnail that just says DIY
Fray jeans seven ways seven easy ways to
fray jeans DIY and um not only is it
have 362,000 views but to your point I
think it'll keep getting views for years
the really small tweak delete
2022 yeah yes just say denim Trends
exclamation point and one of the uh
habits we have at the end of each year
is we actually just look back and we
look at what would cause friction
because people will still watch a video
that's older but if someone goes ah 2022
but now it's just denim Trends seven
easy ways to freay it doesn't mean that
it's the new year if relevant you may
actually change the year but the small
tweak is just delete the year so that's
something you can make actionable right
now think media podcast maybe there's
something in your library that you could
reoptimize and if you actually do want
to uh learn a little bit more about tax
tactics and tips like that um and you
haven't SE our free class think
masterclass.com that's an ond demand
YouTube class that's in the description
as well let's land the plane talking a
little bit about your money plan your
income sources you said YouTube is your
day job and so if we were to pull out a
pie chart and talk about ad Revenue talk
about where income comes from if you
have any affiliate links that are
relevant where's how is YouTube your J
day job break down in terms of
percentages and the ways you make money
so I would say
about
50 30% of the income that I make off
YouTube is just from YouTube ad Revenue
coming in from Google and that that's
you know that and that that to me has
never been anything exciting it's never
been a monetary amount that I've been
like whoa you know it's always kind of
been like okay I mean it's nice but it's
not amazing um although in the last few
months it's grown the rest of it has
been through working with the right
Brands and I don't do it that often
because I am um a a real psycho about
that and the main reason for that has
been you know here's a just blow up my
own spot of of embarrassment here but
I've always felt like I was going
to be a big name I've always felt that
I've always believed that I've always
felt that the Pursuits that I have are
going to work that the dreams that I
have are going to come true I've never
wanted to like work with a brand that
then that video surfaces and it's like
I'm this cheesy girl just co-signing and
promoting everything and feeling shame
for that when I feel like oh I'm at this
place now I don't have to do that stuff
anymore and now I'm like uh like all
these video you know and so I've always
kind of been very careful about that um
for that reason and so I
do
fewer but I require a little bit larger
of a payment if they want to do it and
so it's kind of like you know no problem
but this is the rate to do that and um
because it's not only me creating the
content but it's my endorsement of that
product and that exists across the
internet yeah you're only sponsoring my
YouTube channel but that's my
endorsement that can be found by a
Google search when you search my name
and your company's name and so there is
value in that as well um and so then
there'll be the majority of those things
will be those those sponsored videos and
you know it's it's an interesting thing
there are you get push back sometimes
from people who don't like sponsored
videos you know and I've never quite
understood that um because they're
watching your content for free so it's
kind of like you know right sorry I'll
give you a refund oh wait yeah this was
free um so I don't I never understand
that but you have to just sort of ignore
that and let that stuff go if that does
get to you you got to just know that
this is a job and you you commit a
tremendous amount of time and you
deserve to be compensated for your work
and you deserve to be compensated well
for your work and well for your
education that you're providing and
entertainment that you're providing
providing but yeah the the the it's it's
sort of that kind of a split between the
two
and you
know I've always been eous of hearing
people when they're sharing like what
they make a month off of YouTube when
it's these insane numbers I'm like
that's just incredible but um the the
revenue that comes in every month has
never really felt like a game changer to
me but it's been nice to have kind of a
thing when it comes to working with
brands
do you wait for who's coming in and then
you're just selective or do you also
Outreach directly and email brands that
you want to potentially work with I
really just uh I sift through the ones
that come in I get probably 10 a day um
and so then I just look at the ones that
come in I if it's a a product I'm
familiar with and I know I like then we
start the conversation if it's one that
I that I'm not familiar with I'll do a
quick search on sort of brand confidence
reviews what are people saying about
them um and if it sort of passes that
test then I will always require that
they send me something first with zero
commitment I'm always happy to send it
back but if you're not letting me try it
before I commit there's something wrong
there so you got to give me the time it
takes to know if it works before I
commit to anything um and then that's
the second one and then I have to
actually really um it has to get past me
using it and being something that I'd
recommend to my mom and my sister and if
I wouldn't then I'm I'm not going to do
it because I do have family friends that
watch my content and do BU the things I
suggest and I never want to have that
moment of being like no that was just an
ad why did you do that like I never want
that feeling so I if I wouldn't suggest
it to my mom and my sister then I'm not
going to do it um the only time I've
ever done Outreach and it's been one of
my most lucrative relationships ever was
um the the company Aspire IQ which is
like a you know uh influencer branding
sort of you know connector um and they
they handle the whole thing and you
upload the content directly through the
platform and all that stuff
they put me in I was reached out through
them um for Cricut which is like a
cutting machine and it's this awesome
like it's like your own little personal
robot and it cuts out your designs and
you can do decals and t-shirts and cut
wood and plastic and all this awesome
stuff and I've worked with them now for
probably three years and every video we
do is a dedicated video so the the price
for that video is much higher than
non-dedicated and it's a lot of work but
it's been one of my one of my best
relationships because the rate that they
are willing to meet every time is
something that's worth that level of
work and I really really like it like I
really like the product so it makes it
um really easy to do I'm not like oh
shoot you know hoping no one judges me
for it you've already shared a lot of
advice related to Brand deals and
sponsorships but for many who want to
get started in brand deals and
sponsorships um if you were starting
from scratch what would
you what advice would you give
specifically for that money plan on
YouTube I think you have to have like a
really clear sort of goal set or mission
statement about what this what the
brands and those sponsorships what
they're going to fulfill for you and how
they're going to fit into the overall
image that you're creating the brand
that you're creating and all of that
stuff because I think then that's really
going to dictate what the things you say
yes to and the amounts that you say yes
to as far as actual monetary dollars if
if the goal is you know there are a lot
of people who do sponsored content for
free because they want to appear like
someone who's getting paid to do
sponsored content and that is their
reasoning they're hoping that by looking
the part they'll get those opportunities
and so for them they're willing to do it
for free right others no you're gonna
you're going to pay me to do the thing
um and and that's the way it goes so I
think you have to really know what
you're looking to get out of it if
you're at a place where you know your
channel is providing value I really am
very adamant that you never take
product for trade because to me it's a
really
toxic habit this idea that Brands feel
like they can give product and that
that's your compensation no the product
is the required materials to make your
ad I can't make your ad without your
materials I'm happy to take your product
make your ad and send you back the
product I don't need it but I'm not no
unless it is something you are literally
getting ready to spend your own money on
and you're like no that saved me I was
going to get a new fridge holy cow it
just saved me $1,400 post tax dollars
like score yes duh but if someone's like
I want to send you this new blow
dryer and you make a dedicated video on
it like you're high absolutely not you
know that that's not how it works so for
me I think that even if the even if the
amount is $100 you know or um something
like that I think it's important for
that buy in that you feel like someone
is is buying into the value that you
provide um but again it will come down
for each person where they're at what
their goals are you know what what is
the goal in a year from now and if it's
just to grow to get to a place where
you're doing consistent sponsorships and
hopefully getting on the radar of more
and more Brands then you you bite that
bullet and you do as much as you want
for free for as long as it feels good
but you got to really trust your own gut
and when it starts to feel slimy and it
starts to not feel good anymore you got
to make a change and you either have to
increase your rates or you have to
reduce the ask you have to do something
that you feel like it's a level playing
field and like you're not being used
like you're really this is a really good
partnership I think that energy is
really important in all of these things
because they're like little micro deals
you're doing over and over again and
they can leave you with a with a really
bad feeling if you're not kind of
honoring yourself in it we're doing a
new segment called repeat after me and
uh I'll say a sentence and then you
repeat the sentence and then just finish
the sentence with whatever comes to mind
um if I was starting a brand new YouTube
channel today the first thing I would do
repeat that sentence and then what would
be the first thing you would do if I
were starting a brand new YouTube
channel today the first thing I would do
is create a schedule I would know for
sure I could maintain on the regular
without burning out the biggest mistake
new content creators make is the biggest
mistake new content creators make
is not releasing anything until they
think it's perfect just getting it out
there is where you're going to learn all
the lessons you mean you you you baby
something and you hold it until it's
perfect and then you like release it and
it still probably sucks cuz it was your
first one
so just like get it out that repetition
is where the sweet sauce is you just
learn so much by getting it
out done is better than perfect yes oh
my God I mean I need my own advice but
yeah repeat after me the most important
mindset you need as a content creator is
the most important mindset you need as a
content creator is that you are talking
to one person that's everything I think
it helps you
in being some someone that they feel
connected to it helps in the way that
you actually communicate your words one
of the most annoying things is hey guys
to me I don't want you you're not you're
not talking to anyone else you're
talking to me just talk to me I don't
want to imagine this world of a million
people sitting there on their phone I
want to imagine you're talking to me and
so I think you imagine you are talking
to one person you are teaching one
person you are explaining to one person
you are connecting with them and then it
also takes a little bit of the pressure
off
you know of of worrying about what
everyone's opinion is going to be when
you're just kind of imagining one person
orle you uh have added so much value
today and just want to acknowledge you
for uh just sharing your wisdom for uh
the artistic spirit that you carry in
your work and all of the uh content that
you put on your channel and um you've
shared so many tips here you've been
very generous um there's a lot of cool
things you're doing um for people that
want to check you out where can they
find you online as well as uh some of
these different projects that you have
going on oh yeah thank you it's been so
fun um so the YouTube channel is the DIY
designer um brand new either DIY
personal style or styling hacks every
week and so that's a a blast and like we
said shorts hopefully more often um Tik
Tok is at Orly Shanny that's really
social across the board at Orly Shany so
that's Instagram and uh and Tik Tok and
that is really about again practical
tips style language tips styling hacks
really fun ideas um it's just a fun
little um Escape of of creativity and
and inspirational content I hope and
then style language my style
language.com is the website that is a
beautiful online course if you're
someone who wants to feel more connected
to your personal style you want to feel
like it's something that really
represents who you are and not feeling
the comparison game and being
overwhelmed by Trends and feeling like
crap um it really is about anchoring
into who you really are and so it's a
beautiful process and there's an awesome
Community there and then rockot which is
uh rock.com it's r n o that is a brand
that I started which I hope provides
inspiration because it started off as a
DIY video and launched into a what I
cannot believe successful kind of a
business that it's become it's all
rhinestone cording that gets macrom made
into all of these purse straps and
purses and jewelry and it's all
detachable and multi-functional and
interchangeable um it's really really
fun and so that's root.com and that's
been a business that's been a passion
project and now becoming like a real
thing which I can't believe oh my God
orley thank you so much for coming on
and adding value today on the podcast